jo
[Musique]
comme ici
m
pauli fait
c'est quoi qu'un data
je
m
c
il veut la croyance vas-y une phrase
puis c'est très politique je maîtrise le
soigneur
vous êtes un homme de droite qu'il
aurait dû comme homme de gauche et un
homme de gauche qui nous commande de
dons a simplement choisi tout ça n'est
pas pour vous avez eu la paix libyen qui
mangerait sur le titre dans 48 des
ventes françois mitterrand va se tenir à
l'époque sous des combes et steve comme
témoin j'étais comme mistie bass et
contador gagne un président
[Musique]
j'aurais dû
m
[Musique]
tellement belle et re 100% je n'ai pas
fermé mais non non non tu sûr h toujours
du sud a vraiment cherché j'ai essayé
mais je garde ça en fait si je n'en fais
12 ans
[Musique]
jomo mcg 1500 euros
non non c'est frais
un jour on m'a dit bon la barre
nous sommes là
c'est pas
mais elle m'a dit qu'elle vivait encore
[Musique]
hu
une saga
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là
john holmes